you guys want to hear something
absolutely insane I made more in a year
than the CEOs of McDonald's Ford
Motorola Yahoo and Ikea combined as a
kid in my 20s believe me no one was more
surprised than me and so I'm going to
show you how to make money so fast it
feels illegal the first way to make
money so fast it feels illegal is to
understand value creation I want to tell
you a story I sent my father a picture
of our largest annual event that we held
in our company which licensed to gym
owners um we had a room of 700 plus
people and he said oh that's awesome
that's so many people uh how much did
they pay to be there and I said $42,000
a year and he said oh my God he said do
they know that they're paying that much
and I was like yeah they're aware it's
not like I'm magically siphoning money
from their accounts and um it was like
okay uh now rather than respond and be
like really you know mean about it I was
like well let's walk through this I said
if you were able to pay a dollar and get
$5 back would you do it and he's like
well it would depend I said it would
depend on what he said well what's the
what's the likelihood that the five to
one actually happens I said that's just
the average so some people are below
average some people are about aage he
like okay that feels like a fair bet
well what would I need to do I was like
great question you'd have to dedicate
probably 10 plus hours a week to fully
kind of implementing a new model within
your business he was like
okay how long would it take between when
I started and when I got those types of
results and I said about a year he was
like okay well then yeah I think I would
do it and so that thought process was
kind of the first big unlock to making
so much money that it should feel
illegal which is that you can't sell out
of your wallet you have to sell off of
the value that you're creating for
someone else we were able to charge
significantly more and profit
significantly more than everybody else
in my space and so everyone else in my
space was charging literally a tenth of
what I was able to charge or I prefer to
say command from the marketplace and the
reason that was able to happen was
because I Ed something called the value
equation all right and so the value
equation has four components and I'm not
going to go super deep on it but I'll
just walk you through it real quick so
you've got the dream
outcome which is what's the big thing
that people want so in this instance
it'd be they want to make more money in
their gym they might want to lose weight
they might want to have a fixed their
relationship they might want to look
cool in front of their friends whatever
the next is the perceived likelihood of
achievement or the equal opposite of
that is risk How likely is it that when
I buy this thing I get what I want which
when he asked the question well How
likely is it this is what he's teasing
out the next question is time how long
is it going to take between when I start
and when I get and the longer that is
the less valuable the thing is and then
you have effort and sacrifice which is
how hard am I going to have to try what
am I going to have to start doing that I
don't want to do or stop doing that I do
want to do to be clear the reason that I
I made this value equation is because
for so long many people and you probably
heard them in conent are like provide
value create value but I was like what
does this even mean how does one create
value and so I set out to try and figure
out what makes me want to buy stuff and
so in a hypothetical example you'd want
something that would be immediate it
would be no effort it would be
guaranteed and it would be exactly what
they want the way they want it that
would be the most valuable version of
whatever you could sell and then you
would say let's say that our average is
$100,000 of value all right now in a B2B
setting it might literally be that
because it's a monetary outcome and if
it's a B to C setting selling to
Consumers then we have to abstract the
value of what fitting back into your
high school GS is worth to you or
looking good on prom night or just
feeling good every single day whatever
but we have this Roi uh and then we have
some sort of discount that we're going
to apply to it which accommodates risk
right one is it's in the future I would
pay less for something that is uh that
is guaranteed and immediate then not
guaranteed and at a delay so let's say I
sell tables right so this is a retail
product and you get you would
immediately think oh this is probably
highly commoditized well I'm not so sure
think about it on the lowest end you can
buy a foldout plastic table from uh
Lowe's or Home Depot for probably 50 or
100 bucks I haven't checked plastic
table pricing recently on the flip side
you can buy a
$20,000 handcarved wood table both of
them allow you to put stuff on top of it
and eat right and so the idea is how can
we position our thing separately from
other people now if the dream outcome
for that table is not okay I just need
to have something that I could put stuff
on top of the dream outcome might be
when people walk into my home they feel
immediately impressed so now we're
actually relating this to status so this
is a business because B2B is actually
pretty easy it's just this is how much
money it is and then the rest of your
time is trying to make it easier for
them less risky um and faster business
consumer sometimes you need to spend a
little bit more time on translating what
this status increase might mean for them
and how meaningful that is or the
reverse how terrible and painful it's
been to lack this status right and so if
we have this big expensive nice table
then we say okay here's the status now
the risk of this not happening this is
where we might show trends of this being
a hot thing that many people understand
the value of so the risk of them not
getting the status is lowered the time
is like hey I can have this at your
house by the end of today that would be
something like wow this could happen
right in time for this dinner party I
have or my boss is coming to my house
and then effort and sacrifices don't
worry we have a white glove service that
we'll make sure that we can fit it into
your doorways even though it's this
massive thing and we will assemble it
there for you you just need to say yes
right now and it will be there by the
end of the night and you can have dinner
on it when you have your guest tomorrow
right now we've tied them buying to all
of the value components to getting them
to then be willing to spend $20,000
because it's not about the wood it's not
about the table it's about how much
status is worth to them within this
context and they get to keep it forever
right and so this is how we have to
unpack what we're selling so that many
of you are selling tables and pricing
like it's a plastic table but you're
then trying to half do the work but then
you can't make the margins work with the
white glove because people say I only
want to pay $100 like well I would
deliver it and they're like oh I have to
assemble this too and all of a sudden
they're they're combating you when if
you just had charged more and positioned
it differently you could then give them
all these other things that they want
anyway and the reason this is so
important is that price is the single
largest lever on profit so let's say
we've got a before all right which is
that you sell your tables all right and
you've got an after this obviously works
for services or whatever else you sell
all right and so let's say you charge
$100 for your table and your cost uh for
that table is uh is I'll be extreme here
we'll say it's $50 okay now let's say
that you have other costs like marketing
and sales and other stuff like that that
amounts to $30 all right so that means
that your net profit is going to be 20
bucks when you sell a table gross profit
is 50 net profits 20 okay now let's say
that we reposition our table as this
amazingly valuable thing that is now a
$1,000 table okay now our cost on this
the table itself might be 50 but let's
say we include some of those perks let's
say we've got the hand delivery uh and
things like that okay well let's say
that the delivery is going to be another
$200 uh for one of your guys to go out
there uh and and use the truck gas
whatever so now we got $250 here okay
okay got it and then the other costs
maybe maybe your cost of uh sales goes
up a little bit to sell this you got to
get more leads okay so we'll call it 130
all right so now what are we actually
making in net profit for this table so
we got 3 380 okay I wish I had done
easier math but I think it's 620 here
all right so $620 in profit and so this
is how you can get unreasonably wealthy
in a very short period of time by simply
repositioning what you sell based on the
value provide someone else rather than
the
cost that it costs you and so to put
this in context this is a 31x increase
in profit and so I I'll tell you this
quick story there was a guy that was in
the same exact space as me that paid me
for a Consulting day years ago and when
I looked at his numbers what was
fascinating was that he was actually
selling the same amount of people per
month as I was and so he was spending
the same amount of marketing he was had
the same number of sales guys and he was
closing roughly the same amount as we
were and so what what was interesting
about this and this was a massive lesson
that I learned is that CAC or the cost
of getting a new customer in an industry
as long as you're proficient at
marketing more or less is actually not
that different um that you'd be
surprised I look at a zillion companies
every year and between Industries like a
local plumber and another local plumber
it's not going to be that different and
so the big difference though is that we
were able to make somewhere in the
neighborhood of about eight times uh
more money per customer than this guy
was but here's the crazy part we were
making somewhere near of 50 times more
profit and it's because of this so we
had eight times more money but then it
resulted in so remember this is just
this is a 10x right so this is a 10x
increase in price but it resulted in a
31x increase in profit and so this is
why price is such a strong lever on how
much you make now where it gets
competitive is if somebody else can do
something just like you and do it for
less but there was a I think a Mackenzie
survey where they looked at uh a number
of companies and 85% of them competed on
price and only 1% of them won on price
so it's literally the worst possible
strategy you can have because there's
only one person who wins lowest price
Dan Kennedy said this famously there's
no reward you get for being the second
cheapest competitor you just lose a lot
of money right and so there is however a
benefit to being the most expensive
person and that's going to be a direct
correlation to the amount of value that
you can provide any individual person
and so again it's about thinking how
much is this worth and then can I
deliver it to them and can I eliminate
the risk make it faster and make it
easier for them so that I can get less
discount on the value that I think it
can provide that person now the 2011
version of this is selling out of their
future Wallet not today's wallet and
then the ways that we pull apart that
value so let's say it's a $100,000 of
value there's going to be a discount
that's going to be apply to that
$100,000 based on How likely it is which
is the risk it's going to be based on
how long it's going to take which is the
time it's going to be how how easy it is
how much work they're going to have to
put in and then fundamentally the dream
outcome which if they want to make more
money that one's clear now if you have a
b Toc business a business consumer
business then you have to translate what
looking amazing On Prom Night means to
someone financially or how much pain
they've been in for not having the
specific solution in their life and so
if I buy stuff and it gets to me faster
I'm willing to pay more for it if
someone I buy stuff and they guarantee
it or they make it risk-free or they
show me tons of proof I'm more likely to
pay for it and pay more for it if
someone says oh you don't have to do
anything versus you have a ton of work
associated with it I'm more willing to
pay for it and then the dream outcome is
just making sure that I actually want
this thing versus something else and so
this actually operationalizes what we
can do as business owners how do we make
it faster how do we make it easier how
do we make it risk-free and deliver it
the way they want it so that was the
first of the three kind of beliefs that
I had to break in order to make crazy
money in my 20s the second way to make
money so fast it feels illegal is to
sell in a fast cash conversion cycle if
you don't know what that is I'll explain
it right now this is what allowed me to
have $1,000 in my bank account in
December of
2016 I had a th000 bucks in my bank
account after losing everything for the
second time uh actually that was the
first time I lost everything and then I
lost everything again I think three
months later so just figuratively
imagine I didn't have a lot of money now
10 months later I was able to put in $10
million in sales and bake I think
something probably close to Six Million
in profit all right now here's the crazy
part is that how can you get this to
equate to $10
million in such a short period of time
well the first thing is we got 100 to1
return on our advertising and so every
dollar that I put in so I put I put
$1,000 in ads I made $100,000 and then I
put that $100,000 into ads and I made 10
million and that is fundamentally what
happened and so the constraint of the
business no longer was acquisition but
the reason
that was not the constraint meaning it
wasn't the thing that blocked me from
growing was that we had figured out
something that I call client finan
acquisition which is just a fancy way of
saying using your customers money as a
loan to get more customers so let me
explain so if someone walks into your
business right today and let's say it
cost you $100 in marketing to get them
to buy something from you all right just
keep it really simple so it cost me $100
to get this guy now let's say that my
thing costs
$100 okay now you think oh I grw even
but that thing just like the table is
not going to be 100% margin not likely
and so if it's like the table then I
only make plus 50 on this but I minus
100 because I had to pay this 100 to get
them in the door so I'm actually 50
right now for my first transaction now
should I do this transaction um unless I
have something else to sell not really
because it means I'm spending 100 to
make 50 bad deal now if this person's
going to spend three or four more times
over the next however many months then
yeah it's a good idea but it's still
going to take me time and I'm still
going to to lose money up front now for
me to do this whole thing I got to do it
a different way and so this kind of
enters the new way of doing things which
is I would acquire the customer for $100
same guy right now he's smaller for
whatever reason um and this time I say
okay how can I get this guy to not only
pay for himself that's point one that's
breaking EV on getting customers but
point two is I need to get him to be
able to buy me my next customer and so
if I know my next customer is also going
to be $100 then it means I want him to
pay himself back so I need 100 all right
then I need my next customer so I need
another 100 and then I need to make sure
I get my my cost of my table back which
is 50 all right so I need to make
$250 uh on this transaction for me to
then be able to use this dollars to then
go get my next customer and then I
repeat this
process over and over and over again and
then that result
in this massive amount of money because
if you had a machine that for every
dollar you put into it you got a $100
back out what would your marketing
budget be it would be everything you had
and so here's the crazy part is that
this these types of returns pretty much
only exist in businesses like this type
of Arbitrage which is why if you look at
the wealthiest people in the world they
own assets they own businesses that
generate cash flow because the most
significant Arbitrage that exists is
what it cost to get somebody to buy
something from you and if you have a
well-designed business how much you can
make from that person and so think about
this as every business is a little mini
investing machine and so you pay X to
get customers uh you get y dollars back
and then instead of waiting a year for
10% improvements on the S&P 500 you can
wait one day and get a $100 back and so
why would you invest in anything else
well the richest people in the world
don't they're highly concentrated in the
businesses and industries that they
understand well and so this concept of
clent finest acquisition was the big
unlock that I had and I have in four
times in my life have I gone through
what I would consider a wealth warp
where I had a material change in my net
worth in a very short period of time and
most of the money that I've made has
been in short periods of time and then
followed by kind of like level sets for
a while then I figure out something else
and then I get a huge step up in income
so if you're you're like man we've been
stuck for a while you're usually just
this far away from figure out what that
constraint is now it could have been
capital so for me I didn't have any
money and so this solved my Capital
constraint now what did did not solve it
didn't solve my people constraint it
didn't solve my you know hiring didn't
solve didn't solve uh didn't solve you
know keyman R I didn't solve any of
those problems but it gave me enough
cash to be able to solve those problems
in the future so let me put this in
perspective for you my weight loss
business which was my my actual gyms
which are called United Fitness all
right United Fitness I was able to open
up a new location every 6 months off of
the cash flow no money out of pocket
using this exact same process and so I
would put $5,000 down I would sign a
lease I would begin spending money on
Advertising like $100 a day and for
every $100 that I would spend I would
get somewhere in the neighborhood of
$2500 to $3,000 back immediately and so
in the first week I would then order the
equipment and the next week I would
order the flooring and the next week I
would set up the lobby and get the
painting done and by the fourth week IID
made around $100,000 which is roughly
what it cost to open the business and
give me six weeks of payroll so that by
the end of the promotion that I was
selling which was a six week challenge
at the time I would have something they
have 20 or $30,000 of recurring Revenue
at that gym but it cost me almost no
money out of pocket because I let my
customers pay for my gym for me I would
say I will spend $5 a lead close one out
of five leads on a $500 thing and so I
would pay 25 bucks to get a customer and
make 500 back and then I would take the
rest of that to go get another 25 spend
another $25 to get another customer get
another 500 and then that's how I was
able to to finance the growth of the
gyms and that's how at 23 years old and
then 24 and then 25 it was six locations
and again the constraint was no longer
cash it was trainers it was managers it
was salespeople that's what limited my
growth this was the first time I
discovered this concept and then I was
like oh man I should do this again and
so then I started gym launch 1.0 which
is where I flew out from location to
location and I would make $100,000 at
the gym but then I didn't have to pay
for the buildout and I didn't have to
manage the gym afterward so I could just
take $100,000 it was just me with a
little fold out table probably $100 from
lows um and then just a stack of
contracts and I have videos of me going
through just random places and selling
all day every day for 21 days straight
and then eventually I taught that system
to other people but the average amount
that I'd spend in advertising in those
markets was somewhere there of like1 to
$5,000 and I would make upwards of
$100,000 in that first month and so this
is what allowed me to go from again zero
to doing 32 plus launches in like 18ish
months now the third time that this
wealth Alchemy occurred for me was when
gym launch transitioned to licensing now
in the licensing business this is when
things got even Wilder because I had
fewer operational constraints to scale
and so here I had to keep scaling more
and more sales guys because I had to fly
them out which was actually a tough
value proposition for them they
apparently had wife and kids that wanted
to see them go figure um and so when I
switched to licensing which was just
showing people how I was filling these
gyms that's where we went from the0 to
$10 million in sales in 10 months all
right that's what's that's almost
crazier in my opinion than the second
the second full year of business we did
we did around 16 million in iida all
right that means profit all right and we
did 26 million
TopLine in revenue and again this is
coming from somebody who had then lost
it all because I have made some bad bets
in my life and you're like okay well it
must have only been a fluke that time
well the next business I started was
Prestige Labs which is our supplement
company when from zero 1.7 million per
month this was at the launch this was
month one all right and then I had Allen
which Allen went from zero to 1.7
million per month weirdly that it was
the same number um in six months so
these types of numbers only can occur
when you remove capital or money as a
way of scaling as a thing that blocks
you if you had unlimited money which if
you set up the way that you acquire
customers correctly you can if you think
this video helped you make more money or
would help someone else make more money
it would mean the world to me if you
shared it as a DM or send it to them as
a text so they could watch it and get
the benefits too and Associate those
benefits with you so what you really
want that math to work out to is that
you want two times
CAC plus cogs to equal
30-day cash collected all right uh which
is basically gross profit so you're like
okay that sounds like a really complex
equation I'll say it in in plain English
you want to make two times as much as it
cost you to get a customer and deliver
on that customer within 30 days based on
the amount of cash that you generate
from them in excess of the cogs right
and so if we have let's say $100
remember to get the customer and then
$50 of cogs right then we want to make
sure that we can have $300 I actually
did the math wrong before this is why
equations are useful right we want to
make sure we make $300 on that first
customer so that in the the first 30
days and you're like why is he thinking
about 30 days the reason I'm so
obsessive about 30 days is because that
is the amount of time that anybody can
get interest rate free cash and so
everybody has access to a credit card
and it doesn't matter what your limit is
even if it's a $500 limit that you start
out with which is typically what they'll
start most people on a $500 limit guess
what you can do you pay it off tomorrow
and so if you can get it within that
period of time you'll only be limited by
that card now if you can do it in seven
days then you can repeat the cycle uh
four times in a month if you can do it
every day then you repeat it 30 times in
a month right and so very quickly based
on your speed of collecting the cash
back which is called the cash conversion
cycle you can accelerate your growth I
honestly think the reason that most
businesses don't do this is because they
believe a narrative that because other
people in the industry don't do it they
can't and I think that that belief keeps
many business owners poor the amount of
businesses that I've we've gone into and
been like uh okay well let's just get
people to prepay 3 months at a time
they're like no we it's industry
standard to to do services and then
collect a net net 60 and I'm like yeah
well that's their standard we don't have
to do that well why don't we just give
them incentive to pay and they're like w
well what if what I'm like what if what
what if they say no well they say
they're saying no today sometimes too
might as well like collect more when we
do it and then we say hey we we happen
to build quarterly and with that
convenience we also give you a 5%
discount which of course we baked into
the price anyways right or we add some
sort of onboarding process that normally
people might charge separately for or
that we add in so that we can collect
more cash up front
and I'm willing to give a significant
amount of things up front so that I
don't have my cost of getting customers
as anything that gets in the way of me
growing a business I never want my
ability to get customers or money to get
them to be the thing that limits my
growth and I think that's the reason
that all these businesses that I just
explained went from zero to million plus
per month within a year and I'm saying
within a year as a sof most of them
within 6 months if you want to make more
money ask to get paid sooner so think
about this so if you if you are uh a
minimum wage employee right then you do
work and then you get paid afterwards at
a delay right now if you're a contractor
sometimes uh you can do work and get
paid but usually you get paid and then
you do work if you're a surgeon you get
paid and then months pass and then you
do the surgery if you're an insurance
company you get paid and then you may
not have to ever work at all and if
you're the church you get paid off of
someone's income their Topline a royalty
that goes straight to the church now
royalties happen the same way leans do
so if you if someone owes you money you
can take a lean off the top you skim off
the top and so basically your position
in What's called the capital stack is
predicated on your leverage in the
situation and so if it's up to you you
might as well choose to get paid sooner
now you might be looking at this and
thinking yeah but how do I get all of
that cash up front how do I get people
to actually spend more money with me
faster well it comes down to one you can
either raise the price of your thing or
two you get people to buy more stuff
immediately and so one of the big
misconception business owners have is
that they're afraid of making offers and
so I want to be very clear you don't
want to try and force someone to do
something people don't like to be sold
but they do love buying right I mean
think about how much money Amazon makes
people love buying and so what we want
to do is make offers when it's
convenient for them to take them and so
an offer only doesn't work if it's
something that they don't want or you
present it at the wrong time or you know
advanced verion 3 they don't it's not
being delivered in the way they want it
to be delivered all right and I'll tell
you a quick story about that so when I
was in the in the weight loss business
we discovered that there were some
customers that would come in and they
didn't want to buy gym services and I
was like okay well that's lame but I
then figured out hey why don't I in
invite them to a nutrition seminar and
so we invite them to nutrition seminar
even though they said no to our services
think how crazy this is they come in
virgy we try to sell them they say no I
say hey can I just help you with your
food and they say sure then they go to
the nutrition seminar and they buy more
than the people who bought gym services
on average and so I was like oh we just
needed to make them a different offer to
solve the same problem so they wanted to
lose weight still they just didn't feel
like sweating they wanted to take
supplements and eat differently fine so
learning to make multiple offers to a
customer is not only beneficial for them
because you help them solve the problem
in more ways it's also beneficial for
you because you get more cash up front
and so thinking through how do I get
someone to buy because there's something
that people enter called a hyper buying
cycle so if someone makes any kind of
new decision especially if it's like
okay I'm now somebody who's going to
start taking care of their lawn hey I'm
I just bought this new car hey I I'm
going to run a marathon there's these
little cycles that people enter there's
these buying windows and what a
traditional business owner would say
let's say somebody who runs a marathon
they they sign up for the marathon and
then they go to The Running Store when
they go to The Running Store they have
to buy some shoes now the store owner
says oh I don't want to offer them you
know fancy socks or an i iPod wristband
or new tank tops I don't want I don't
want to seem like I'm being pushy but
what are they going to do they're still
going to go buy that stuff because they
have to get the whole thing and so
there's this natural problem solution
cycle that continues over and over and
over again within every customer's
purchases provided the first problem is
solved with the first purchase and then
that then opens up the next problem so
once you have your shoes what else do
you need you're going to need socks once
you have socks what else you're going to
need you're going to need shorts once
you have shorts what else you going need
you need tank top that doesn't you know
rub on your on your your underarms
you're also going to need an iPod
carrier all of these different things
you're also going to want the number
thing you might want a coach you might
want an app you might want a hydration
thing like there's there's supplements
there's all these different things that
stem from this and everyone's afraid to
ask so just make the offer available and
if they choose not no worries if you're
like if you go buy something and then
the thank you page says hey would you
want this too if you're offended by
that well the business doesn't really
care I put it that way because other
people won't be offended by it and will
be happy that you made it available and
more can convenient for them so
ultimately you're providing more value
and you're getting rewarded for it yeah
and and at each one of these uh upsells
that you might want to include you still
think through each of the value equation
components so you still think what's the
dream outcome they ultimately want how
do I make it risk-free for them how do I
do it faster and how do I make it easier
so number one we're charging as much as
we possibly can because we're doing it
based on value not based on cost the
second thing we're doing is we're
structuring our economics of the
business how we upsell how we down sell
so we can generate more cash in the
first 30 days so that we can get enough
to pay for this customer and the next
customer and delivering for both of them
in that same time period so that cash
and getting customers is not limited the
business and the third way to make money
so fast it feels illegal is to
understand wealth Alchemy and ignore
taxes or kind of just play the game the
right way so let me walk you through an
example so let's say that you give away
free trials of your thing okay cool
makes sense we give away free trials and
let's say a free trial of your thing
cost $100 to get someone to start fine
now let's also for simple math say the
trial is $100 per month all right we'll
keep this really simple all right that's
the price that's our free trial after
the conversion okay now let's say that
we get uh one out of uh three people who
start a free
trial to become a customer okay that
means that it's going to cost us
$300 right this times three to get a
customer okay now let's say that we know
one out of three customers becomes a
permanent customer meaning once they get
on our subscription they never leave
which would mean that our permanent CAC
is somewhere close to $900 okay now if
our price here is $100 a month then that
means that the annual
revenue Anor recurring revenue is
$1,200 per year okay so we pay $900 to
make $1,200 per year Well if you had a
stock that you could buy for $900 and
then it and then it sent you back $1,200
um within 12 months you probably be like
that's a great investment now if it kept
doing that you'd be like it's
unbelievable investment well let me show
you how much more wild this can really
get now let's say that we have this
let's just say this is a software
company all right so if it's a software
company let's say that it trades at 10
times Topline which is fairly typical
for like a B2B SAS business as long as
you have good retention metrics which is
why this is so important permanent CAC
permanent customer so if we know that
then it means that we're actually making
$122,000 in Enterprise Value which means
how valuable the business is that can
create this kind of
money now here's where it gets even
nastier is
that this is tax-free and so you get
paid this money but you also get this
it's not either or it's an and so when I
figured this out I was like
oh this is how people just make stupid
money really fast and so let's let's
work this out okay I want to make $120
million let's say that was my goal okay
so $120 million I would have to how many
$112,000 customers in terms of
Enterprise Value would I need well let's
go look all right so I need 10,000
customers of this of this $900 times
10,000 to
get my $120 million Enterprise Value
here so let me ask you a question does
10,000 time 900 so you're telling me if
I pay $9
million I can make this year an increase
of a 120 million in asset value
taxfree and and make $12 million in
Revenue that I add for the 9 million and
so
walk through this in sequence with me
you spend 9 million you get back $12
million in annual revenue and that $12
million of annual revenue is worth1 120
million that you paid zero taxes on that
is the
game this is the wealth Alchemy this is
how it works this is how these software
companies that IPO at three billion how
in four years it goes from you know
nothing right to a multi-billion dollar
thing if you look at how much it cost
them to get customers you're like like
when I understood this I was like oh
it's literally just a massive Arbitrage
between the permanent cost of acquiring
customers relative to the annual value
relative to the Enterprise Value
multiple and then those three things
spit together is what creates this
massive discrepancy between what you put
in and what you get out which because of
my fancy fancy t-shirt here I will show
you is the definition of Leverage and so
the reason that there are two symbols
that are woven into the acquisition.
comom logo which is supply and demand
and a full Chrome for leverage is that
you get more for what you put in and so
if you have two businesses right so
let's let's let's paint this out let's
say we had a different business that we
did the same thing but let's say that we
actually these types of businesses
whatever business it was traded on
bottom line and so if the business uh
was doing 12 million let's say that it's
doing $3 million in profit whatever this
new other business is okay it's doing $
million in profit and let's say that we
get a uh 7x multiple on the on this uh
on this eida which is fancy word for
profit which means that we have $21
million now if I paid 9 million for 21
million would I be down for that
probably I mean it's still a 2 point
something X it's not bad but this is why
picking a good opportunity vehicle
because in both of these situations you
still spent the $900 per customer you
still make the $1,200 per year but the
big difference was how much is that
$1,200 per year worth yeah and so let's
dive into this permanent customer
concept for a second this concept took
me so long to grasp as an entrepreneur
what every business owner needs to focus
on is how do I not lose customers and
the reason for that is that let's
compare two businesses all right so
let's say you've
got business a and business B okay so
business a acquires 100 customers your
one and loses 100 customers and the next
year they double their acquisition they
double their marketing and sales they
acquire 200 customers and then year
three they you know they lose all 200
and then they they they add another 50%
acquisition they do 300 customers in
year three okay so it's a 300 customer
business now Company B sells 100 first
year now second year they do aund they
keep their first 100 but they don't
increase their marketing and sales so
now they have 100 from last year plus
100 to this year and then the third year
they have 100 from two years ago 100
from one year ago and then 100 this year
both of these businesses A and B have
300 customers but which company would
you rather own this one absolutely no
question so why is that you want time to
be on your side not your enemy because
time is going to pass no matter what and
you want a business where no matter what
happens it just keeps growing so you can
sell the same amount of customers you
could even not sell customers and still
make money and so this is a far less
risky business and as a result of that
if you recall the value equation from
earlier an investor is valuing a
business fundamentally on the same
things which is How likely is this to
occur how much effort and sacrifice is
this going to take what is the time
delay between now and when this becomes
this ultimate thing right and so the
same process is still done obviously at
a slightly more complex scale but when
we're thinking about permanent customers
this companies is turning customers into
permanent customers company a is just a
churn Factory they sell something want
and people don't like it and they leave
which means the only way to grow this
business is market and sell more but
that is only a oneway road at some point
you sell through all the customers
within a given base and so it would
behoove us to spend more time just
figuring out how to not lose people so
that 10 years from now what like as we
keep going because this this map would
continue this guy is going to slow down
right it being able to double Marketing
sales every single year is tough but
just keeping the customers you had for
10 years significantly easier but people
don't focus on because it's not as sexy
but this is where the real leverage
occurs and this is where that wealth
alchemy that I was referencing earlier
this is how you get stupid RIT and so
let me give you a real word example so
Starbucks do you want to know what their
LTV per customer is
$114,000 that's how much they make per
customer and that is why Starbucks makes
so much money so you think about these
like high ticket businesses and stuff
that's all around B2B whatever they're
making $14,000 per customer from like
everyone and so what does it cost to get
somebody to to buy a cup of coffee I
promise you significantly less than
$14,000 and this relates back to my very
first point that I was telling you where
I had another company that was in the
same space as me the cost to get a
customer for Starbucks to get somebody
buy coffee is probably similar to a
Dunkin Donut it's probably similar to
another random you know coffee shop down
the street the difference is that they
had engineered their model such that
people wanted to keep coming back that
they became recurring or reoccurring
customers so the difference there really
quickly is recurring means it's a
subscription like netflex reoccurring
means that you buy on a regular basis so
you might buy Coca-Cola for example or
whatever one of their products that you
like you're probably not on a
subscription for it but you buy it when
you're out at restaurants or you buy it
when you ship it to your house whatever
or you just buy Costco when you're there
from a distribution center either way
you are a reoccur customer for them and
so figuring out what is my cost of a
permanent customer and all you have to
do is figure because a lot of businesses
have this is you say okay let's say
you're an agency a super high- turn
business typically okay there are some
customers that have been with you for a
long time and we will I will consider
somebody who's been with you two plus
years as a permanent customer within the
context of what we're talking about now
you might figure out and this is why
this is so important that there it's
only one out of every 10 of your
customers becomes a permanent customer
well then you say okay well how much
does it cost to get a customer multiply
it by 10 this is actually the recurring
base that we're trying to build everyone
else is just sifting through the you
know the weat from the the the shaft I
think is what it's called Uh to get the
just get the kernels right the main the
main part and if you want to be smarter
about it you can say huh well it takes
us 10 customers to get these ones but
what if these customers look and smell
walk and talk a little bit differently
than the other nine well I'll bet you if
we changed our advertising and attracted
only those types of customers we would
be able to get a higher hit rate on that
so even if our CAC for this specific
Avatar doubles but we get it to one out
of three it cost us $600 to get a
customer rather than $1,000 and we're
still winning overall and so so the big
picture here is that number one we have
to sell off a value we have to use the
value equation to make things less risky
faster and easier for the customers once
we do that we are decoupled from a race
to the bottom price War number two once
we know what our premium prices we want
to pull that cash forward and speed up
the cash conversion cycle so that
capital or money is not the limiter of
the business and so we can get customers
on demand and we can do so profitably
we're literally getting paid to get new
customers they pay us they finance our
acquisition which why I call it customer
Finance acquisition and then finally we
understand the game of wealth Alchemy
which is of the customers that we
acquire what percentage of them become
permanent customers and they become the
reoccurring Revenue base within this
business and then that reoccurring base
is what we are going to be valued on and
then what is that value multiple and so
then we just look at the Arbitrage
between what it costs us to get a
permanent customer versus what our
Enterprise Value multiple is going to be
which is until the day you sell it
growing taxfree and so I'll show you one
last little hack here that I think is
important so let's just say in this
business it's in the original vehicle so
you can just forget about this little
side Stu so it's in the original vehicle
and let's say that we've got $3 million
in profit for this business it doesn't
matter okay so you have three million
bucks in profit in this business and
let's say that you live in a high tax
state and you get tax 50% for tax
reasons so you're going to take home
$1.5 million after taxes now you're butt
hurt about this cuz you're like what the
heck government you're taking half of
what I made but if you added $12 million
to the business and you spent this money
to do that what did you really increase
well you increased your personal net
worth by $120
million and so if you had1 120 million
plus the 3 million that you made in cash
flow and you only had to pay 1.5 million
on
123 now you're paying I don't know 1 .5%
in
taxes when I realized this it
fundamentally shifted how I played the
game I I I I was really obsessed with
tax strategy and trying to maximize all
these loopholes when the biggest and
most obvious one is just build something
valuable and as long as you keep
building it and you don't want to cash
it out all of that growth is taxfree and
compounds and the the the clue that I
got on this was realizing I was like
this is before Elon moved from
California so I was like elon's in
California I was like Zuckerberg is in
California and I looked at the the
Forbes list said all these people in the
US were in California but I was like but
California has the highest taxes how is
this possible I was like oh they
understand something about wealth
creation that I don't understand what is
that and that was when I dove deep and
understood this level of wealth creation
or what I like to call now wealth
Alchemy if you like this video you'll
love these